The average age of an apple in a U.S. grocery store from the day it was picked
until the day it gets into your mouth is 11 months.
And this is usually shocking to people.
And it's because we've designed the system.
The last big push for agriculture was more cheap food.
And we've optimized maybe not for the best goal: the goal of transport, the goal of cheapness,
but not the goal of nutrition.
The goal of environmental stewardship, which is now forefront in a consumer's mind,
who says, "Where did my food come from?
How good is it for me?"
And those questions require so much more information.
This is Caleb Harper, a research scientist
at MIT.
As the son of farmers who advised him to get out of the family business and into tech instead,
Caleb decided to merge the two worlds.
We design things that we call food computers.
And the reason I call them that is because
I want to engender that imagination,
that curiosity.
A food computer is essentially a box that
controls and designs a climate.
If you think Star Trek or you think Willy
Wonka, that's exactly what we're going for.
It's a tabletop machine and technology platform that lets you program a climate
for the crop you want.
The build components and instructions are accessible and that’s exactly what Caleb
and his team have in mind.
We're focused on open source technologies
because we believe that that next revolution in agriculture has to be based on open science.
That was one of the big misses from technology in the last 30 years was keeping it proprietary,
keeping it closed.
I have an IP strategy, which is to put everything in the public domain.
The Open Agriculture Initiative released their first prototype in 2015, giving curious potential
farmers a chance to experiment.
They’ve tweaked the design since, and released their newest version, the PFC.
Basic tinkering skills not included.
The smallest one behind me is for the maker, the student, the enthusiast, the home body,
the hacker, the scientist that wants to get
involved in their own house
or in their own labs.
The parts include circuit boards, sensors,
lights, and cameras to monitor the plant.
A seed has so much embedded technology inside of it already.
So when you take a certain set of genetics and you put it inside of a certain phoneme or
climate, it will express something.
That's called a phenotype.
We want to understand under what conditions do those genetics express flavor, nutrition,
size, color.
And it has a lot more to do with its environment than its genetic predisposition.
So we design CO2, and temperature, and humidity, and light spectrum, and light intensity,
and minerality of the water, and oxygen of the water, then trying to make sense
out of what happened.
The results get converted into a digital climate recipe, that can be uploaded
for anyone to use.
If you want to build a food computer, first
know that you are on the front lines
of what we call the nerd army.
Now the project is spread across 65 countries, 3,000 collaborators, and we're starting to
build a base of knowledge that will actually be viable for machine learning.
Machine learning and artificial intelligence can make sense out of all the data these food
computers generate, tweaking the recipes and helping create a shared language
for indoor farming.
The power of that is that all of a sudden, agricultural research is not docked geographically.
It doesn't have to be Ag research is only
relevant in Iowa to Iowa.
All of a sudden, Iowa can become a digital climate and that digital climate can be shared
across 10,000 food computers.
Inside Caleb’s lab are these enormous food servers, where they’re tackling
even bigger questions.
We're looking at the effects of predators,
the effects of climate change.
And all of this has a big effect on the ultimate result of what that plant has to offer you
in terms of flavor and nutrition.
And with climate change starting to impact the world’s food supply, companies are starting
to pay close attention.
70% of the world’s hazelnut trees are grown in Turkey and lately they’ve been hit hard
by hail storms and freezing temperatures.
Ferrero, the company behind your favorite
hazelnut spread, is working with Caleb’s
team to see if they can grow hazelnut trees in new locations.
We ran a matrix of different genetic varieties of hazelnut trees.
And then we subjected them to South African climate, to Chilean climate,
and to Australian climate.
Out of these 12 varieties, we found one that not only survived but thrived in these kinds
of high heat intensity situations.
It's totally novel.
But let’s get one thing straight, this box
isn’t exactly going to be your own custom
grocery store.
I don't believe that the future holds food
computers in every house
that feeds them everything they need.
But what's really cool is we're learning about the genetic difference between human to human.
And that's providing so much insight into
what you should eat versus what I should eat,
versus what someone else should eat.
Then I see a food computer in every home, because it'll grow something very,
very specific to you.
And it'll be used much more like a pharmacy rather than a constant food source.
By putting the controls directly into your
hands, Caleb hopes that this is only just
the beginning of a micro-farm revolution.
Can you imagine anything more important than food?
How we're all going to eat in the future and that we can't see above that to see some big
common understanding?
Making some of this open, interoperable across all these different disciplines
will be better for the world.
For more science documentaries, check out this one right here.
Don’t forget to subscribe and keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.